you need to be a visionary you need to
think about big things and vision and
long term and and
otherwise you don't have you know really
your direction and the big picture
[Music]
thank you so much for joining me how are
you good how are you
i'm i'm great it's so fantastic to have
you we know it's
each other for quite some time now for
quite a few years
all the way back from the robotics team
when and when you so generously
it came and helped mentor our team a
relatively rookie team and
and you've built some some really
incredible incredible
projects and and mentorship in in in
not far okay and so tell me a little bit
about your journey
where do you come from and how do you do
that transition from an entrepreneur
investor
to education and mentorship
yeah so first of all thank you for
having me um
i think that probably the best
definition is to say that i'm a serial
entrepreneur
started in the software market
in this israeli army and
found myself in
focusing on software my first startup
the one that i did the first exit was in
the crm eop
markets i moved to the states lived in
the us for five years with my family
came back to israel
just before 9 11
and decided that i need to find
something interesting to do
once retired because the exit was
good enough and after you know like 18
months of doing nothing and going to
coffee shops
you need to figure out that you do want
to do something
and i found myself in by coincidence i
must say
working with the with the high school
kids
and robotics is is an interesting
platform not necessarily because the
kids
will eventually focus on robotics in
their
adult advanced life but rather because
it's a combination of different
disciplines
including mechanical engineering
software
um system engineering working in a
team um understanding and handling
priorities
so modern robotics in a way it's a great
platform if you want um to work with
kids and in
start some kind of an excitement in them
um to be part of the technology a market
or technology world
uh and this is basically what it is it's
a trigger
but ellie before we get to deeper into
the robotics i have to understand
because
you know most people who who end up
devoting you're pretty well over 100
time towards you know education and
mentorship they often come
from from those types of backgrounds
that they've done that for
for quite some time you're coming in as
an entrepreneur investor
serial entrepreneur you're saying all of
a sudden devoting 100 of your time
or 150 of your time to uh helping mentor
kids so how does that work
well first of all a hundred percent to
120 percent
is is a relative definition um if you
want you have 26 hours a day
and you find the time to do things that
you like
i kept doing and i'm still doing a lot
of work with entrepreneurs
adult entrepreneurs what you find
out and what attracted me to work also
with
with high school kids is that if you
think about it
this is the next generation you talk
about the millennials now
um even if they are now 15 16
years old in 10 years they are the next
generation entrepreneurs
so even if you are focused on um
entrepreneurs and startups and you are
looking for the next generation
you find yourself talking to kids
they are very
[Music]
intuitive very innovative
so i think that what you find out when
you work with kids
around those areas of innovation
um and out of the box thinking
um is that you can get great results
when you have the mixed teams of adults
and kids
and this is where i started with i can
say that now about
what 20 20 years later i came back to
israel
20 years ago back from the states 20
years later and now i'm working
with a lot of of startups that are
combining and we'll talk about it later
combining kids
and adults it's a great combination
because you have
great ideas coming from them yeah they
are less mature of course
they don't have all the professional
skills you are looking for
in the same time they are very very
innovative and
are still capable of thinking out of the
box right something that we are losing
as we are aging and getting a profession
right
and this is very interesting uh for the
ecosystem in israel
and we find i can point out now five
companies
in the hub that we are running here in
emma cafe where we have
kids 11 and 12 graders that are part of
those startups
just because you know they met each
other and are now involved
no no a hundred percent and and i'd love
to get
to understand a little bit better about
with this this community that you're
building there so
you know and what you're doing with
mcfaffir is not what an ordinary
robotics team
does in israel all over the world and
and it's gone beyond simply the six
week first robotics competition uh right
it's gone much beyond that
uh so ellie yeah talk to me a little bit
about why
like why did what is the community
within this education sphere like like
first is and
and what you're doing there and then
talk to me about what you're doing
outside of just the first program
sure so again
it's not a secret that the traditional
formal
uh education system the school system
is not working or not working very good
um now the coffee 19 days
make it even more difficult you know for
that system
um but kids are looking for something
interesting to do
everybody is bored the typical answer
you get from a typical
high school a kid that is coming back
from school and you know how was your
day and the answer is boring
or you know okay it's the best you can
get
like a very a very shallow okay
like you know and the idea was to try to
build some kind of an ecosystem
that will first of all and before
everything else
will reignite if you want
people and make them excited about
their daily operations so the whole idea
was to create some kind of an ecosystem
some kind of an environment
where people could be excited about what
they are doing put aside their
age whether those are kids or or adults
and since i'm involved you know for like
30 something years in technology and in
the startup
ecosystem um we said and with
me together with another partner his
name is iran and we are partners here
in in israel both of us are coming
separately
but coming from the item itec sector
and the idea was to create some kind of
a local
if you want domestic ecosystem
that will be part of the community at
large if you want
so it's not only your neighborhood but
it's the area around you i would say 20
30 40 50 000 people
in that in that area emmy krefer is an
example of the heifer valley
here in israel and try to bring
content or or create an enabling
platform
around entrepreneurship innovation out
of the box thinking
not necessarily technology but
technology is a great
a start for many of those right put
everything in place
which means content lectures you name it
put it there and allow them to consume
if you want the content and the place
and everything you put in you know for
them when they need it
and develop themselves right so
we are mentoring and we provide the
space
but it's an hype if you want a hybrid
solution because it's a combination of
an open space uh you know like we work
together with an accelerator and
eventual fund and we do all of those
together
but not in a predefined program that
says uh well
welcome to our accelerator you have two
years
you get 1 million at the end you need to
be able to to fly or refresh you know
sometimes it works most of the times you
know
you know it doesn't work right and right
and the idea here
was was to try and create the platform
so platform is a place to be offices
maker space
um cnc and you know you name it
everything that you need
to really make things and not only think
about them right if you want to do it
bring a lot of content from leading in
you know leading ideas and ceos of
companies that are coming and talking to
the future entrepreneurs
in different areas uh do mentoring
and really bring mentors that could take
them forward
and have a venture fund to do small
early stage
a pre-seed if you want investments all
of that
is aiming now not only adults the usual
entrepreneurs
but also kids right and
try to mix them um i don't know
how you call it in the u.s but in israel
you know we have this spot that you do
like a poke
so which is so i don't know what's the
terminology
it probably the same way a melting pot
yeah
so this is this is the best description
of what we're trying to do
you put in a lot of good materials good
people mentoring
location you do it very slowly
you need to be you know not to try to to
expedite things
you rather need to do it slowly and you
start to see the community really
beating in front of you
and i can say that now in in emmett
heifer here
three years later we have
really a full place we have a waiting
list of like 10 15 people that are
trying to join and we don't have any
offices for them a
we have more than 100 100
kids high school kids that are involved
in any given
a time today yeah more than 100 wow a
probably next year we are going to have
more
a covered 19 created the situation that
as i said school is boring
schools are now cooperating with us and
saying well you know maybe
maybe the informal education
is not so bad and it's interesting and
they cooperate with us
wow what do i i'm really curious about
what what do you see in that space so
when you
when you take high schoolers and i'm a
huge advocate of this myself but
you take high schoolers and you give
them a different purpose that's
intrinsic informal education that they
actually get to build something and
provide a product given
executing on what they're learning what
do you see
outside of the outside of the lab do
they change at all
are they more confident in different
areas
so great question i would say that the
the main
think about it as a toolbox and you
basically equip
them with with a new toolbox for life i
would say that 90
of the value that we provide to those
high school kids
is not technical at all it has nothing
to do with robotics or space or other
areas that we are supporting
it's rather on a personal toolkit
of how to be part of a team how to
integrate
it things it doesn't matter what kind of
integration what we call system
engineering
processes understanding of how do you
really manage
a personal priorities and one of the
interesting feedbacks we are getting
from kids and from the teachers in
school
is that once they finish the first year
here you know in our program
they're coming back to school and
everything in school is very very easy
for them
really they easily have yeah they easily
handle
the timeline and they do the tests and
usually the grades are going up
although they spend about half of their
time here right they are spending
afternoons and nights in the weekend and
you need to really push them back
out because if it's up to them they
spend every minute here
it's a community for them so all the
friendships and everything it's like
youth movement if you want which by the
way is something we are doing
right now in israel with the ministry of
education
and ministry of science turning all that
type of operation into a recognized
world movement
it's called what you're going to call
nation which in hebrew stands for
um robotica which is youth
uh starting robotics
something robotics and the whole idea is
to really recognize the fact
that it is a used movement with
everything involved
so a personal skill sets what they call
the 21st century skill sets
is is most of you know the the best
value they are getting
interesting to say that we see a lot of
activities around
us from different um
the you know the ministry of education
uh the idf
the you know the israeli army they are
looking for those kids not because they
know how to do robotics
but they are much more mature in yes
in the understanding of how to work in a
team right a
we do a find a lot of situations where
kids that will
not the best ones in high school
are finding things to really
uh excel and do things here and be
leaders in different areas
um we work a lot with the girls
and fighting very successfully
um the situation where girls are not
getting into technology for different
reasons this is not an israeli problem
it's a worldwide one a very successfully
uh
working with girls and really have a
mixed
groups working with different parts of
the israeli society
that are not really into technology and
we're doing very well with them as well
uh through different connections we have
a
so the whole idea is using technology we
are doing it especially with two
if you want programs or titles one of
them you mentioned
which is robotics and the first
organization the other one
is something that is developing all over
the world now which is what is called
the new space or commercial space
applications that are trying to or
starting to look at
space not only as a an intelligence
government type of
area but rather commercial or private
sector that are looking into those areas
a lot of startups in israel in this area
we are using it
uh to attract kids to come to us so we
have now
a mouse a simulator that we are building
here
in together with the kids that are going
you know that is going to have
like an underground a lava
type of whatever
and you're going to have a mission to
mass and a control room
the whole idea is really trigger them
bring them in
once they are in we get them
but all you have to ask so at the end of
the day you know you're running these
these programs but how do you do this at
scale right so as an entrepreneur still
entrepreneur investor it's all
it's all about you create the value you
find the product market fit
you create an amazing experience now
let's how do you replicate this
all over the world because i'm convinced
i went through i went through some of
these programs with you
with your mentorship i know how
incredible it is i know the tools that
it gave me but
but how do you get this how do you get
every kid in the world to have this
experience
so it's a great question and it's a
question that we started you know asking
ourselves about three years ago
when we started the first location here
in mcheffer and we are
six partners all of us by the way are
coming from the high tech sector
so this is not real estate for us right
the real estate partners is just
an enabling platform and this was
exactly the question that we're asking
is this um operation is some kind of a
one-man or two-man or
five-man operation and that's it or can
you really
replicate can you really scale it took
us
two and a half years to really examine
the model
uh refine it if you want um
about a year ago we started to work on
our second
location up in israel near the halal
we are now working on it building the uh
the new location over there that will be
location number two and hopefully
it opened around pesach you know spring
of 2021
and we are already talking about the
third location
that is going to be some kind somewhere
around recovered
uh so a little bit south of uh
if the whole idea is to do it outside of
the big cities
do it in areas where people are looking
you know you have
good a community
high skills on one hand but people that
are bored are looking for
interesting things to say just to do
each um
you could provide a since you are out of
the big city
real estate is cheaper so you could do
things that you cannot do
you know in tel aviv or in major
locations
uh like mc israel now is going to be all
around space
and we are building now a new way a
planetarium over the
a really sophisticated a special
telescope that
is a sun telescope so not only a
regular one a lot of development around
this
in america we do a lot of robotics and
agriculture
which is something we could do here
because we have tons of areas around us
and better sites are the easiest thing
to do
um and yeah i think that
we i would say even on something which
is important
you learn very early that if you want to
have this model working it cannot be
based
on philanthropy right it must be a
business model
now why is that why do you think that is
because
long term it's very easy to get a
donations funds to build something
but it's basically impossible to keep
getting those donations to operate it
right so you must in a way
come with a plan that will be not will
be not only sustainable
and and could a a fund itself
but be profitable otherwise you don't
have the funds you need
to really you know do the investments at
the beginning
and took us about two years to make sure
that we understand how to make it
profitable now don't get me wrong
profitable
while still understanding that there are
impact
aspects for your investment community is
important
so it's not only maximizing the return
of investment
in terms of funding and money it's also
in community value
incredible but the model needs to be
sustainable it needs to be profitable
and once you do you could do whatever
you want
and very interesting to say another
thing the government the different
agencies
that are and you know i'm not blaming
them are never
a first adopters are not
they tend to join in later if you could
prove that what you're doing is really
working and sustainable and bringing
value
right once you do they are eager to join
because this is a success and they could
be part of it and i'm not cynical what i
want to say is that this is the
the way it works yeah so
if once you do it i met yesterday the
ministry
the minister of science
and he came to um to mc israel to see
what we are building over there
and now the ministry of science is
supportive
and we are getting money for different
things we want to do but this
is only after we proved that we we are
able to bring money
do what we need which is funny but you
know how they say about banks
the bank wants to lend you money only
when you don't need it
right so in a way similar here you need
to be on your own
be able to support your ideas and prove
that it's working
everybody else will join you later on
which is fine ellie
this is uh insightful and inspiring that
i i just love what you're doing there
and i have no doubt that it'll continue
to scale
and i know the impact that you
personally had on me and emma
and the whole matzah had on myself and
my friends and i'm and i'm watching
everybody also you know in the united
where i served i pretty much
recognize everybody from these amazing
community and it really is a youth
movement
uh just it's around technology less
about camping it's a different youth
movement
before we go i need three words that you
would use to describe yourself
yeah this is also always interesting to
uh
you know to look back and and and think
about it
i would say probably
i'm very focused in everything i do and
people that are working with me
know it some kind of a combination i i
usually say that i'm a tall person i'm
not very tall not at all
but totally in the sense of your head
needs
need to be you know up there in the sky
you need to be a visionary you need to
think about big things and vision and
long term and and
otherwise you don't have you know really
your direction and the big picture
in the same time you need to be a very
connected to the ground
right your fitness well you know
connected to the ground and need to be
into the details
uh there is a phrase that somebody used
that says you know
think big and act small i really believe
believe in this
i think that we need to and i'm trying
to be
a strategic or think strategy in
everything i'm doing
uh which i think is a good combination
to describe me some kind of
emphasis on strategy together with very
practical
um approach to life and i believe that
the combination
is what makes it not only interesting
but i
will allow myself to say successful
so this is wonderful and i can't wait to
come visit the
greater space and it's it's just
incredible the work that you're doing so
thank you very very much
my pleasure thank you